You know what we all make mistakes,
second chance I hope.
I've been a good guy.
As disgraced movie mogul Harvey Weinstein
half-asses his way through sex addiction rehab,
more and more women, ranging from Oscar winner
Lupita Nyong’o,
to former teen star Molly Ringwald,
keep coming forward with stories about his
abusive and sometimes criminal behavior.
Even his brother and long time business partner
Bob Weinstein has disowned him
calling him indefensible, crazy and remorseless.
But the Weinstein story is not just about
the end of a career,
it's about the end of an era.
The Miramax co-founder is only the latest
in a long line of powerful older men
whose professional lives have ended with revelations
of long term harassment and worse.
Fox News cashiered it's founder, Roger Ailes
and star host Bill O'Reilly
because of similar charges.
And Bill Cosby's 2014 comeback was destroyed
after claims surfaced
that he drugged and raped over a dozen women.
The head of Amazon Studios was forced to resign
last week
after he was accused of repeatedly and insistently
propositioning
the producer of the streaming service's acclaimed
series 'The Man in the High Castle.'
Weinstein was widely and rightly derided for
blaming his decades long behavior
on 'having come of age in the 1960s
and 70s' he said
'when all the rules about behavior and workplaces
were different.'
Why don't you let me tape you?
Doing what?
Talking.
About what?
About sex.
Among other things, such a defense ignores
the inconvenient fact
that the 70s ended nearly four decades
ago.
Today on the press and on the radio the American
career girl, married or single,
is a favorite subject for discussion.
But he is right that workplace expectations
have changed,
and that's largely because the workplace itself
has changed,
About 60% of women are in the workforce
compared to just 43% in
1970.
In fact, more than half of all management,
professional and related positions
are held by women.
The pay gap has also essentially vanished.
A study of 33 countries including the United
States
found that when comparing workers doing the
same job
men made just 1.6% more than women.
As I travel the world and represent our company,
I listen a lot.
With higher pay, positions and status comes
more workplace power.
My name is Victoria Valentino and I met Bill
Cosby in 1969, I was a folk singer-
I'm Louisa Moritz-
My name is Joyce Emmons-
Power that is amplified by social media
and other technologies that empower dissent
and make it harder and harder to maintain
a sexist status quo.
He won the Heisman trophy with his DNA rape
kit.
There's a real issue that in the aftermath
of the Harvey Weinstein revelations,
behavior that is merely boorish or one time
only
will be conflated with systemic sexism and
far more reprehensible crimes.
But surely it's more than coincidence
that the Weistein scandal broke just after
Hugh Hefner,
the absolute personification of old-school
pre-equality male sexual identity,
was being lowered into the ground.
The old days, and the old ways are being laid
to rest
and that's a very good thing for all of us
regardless of gender.